a.d
a couple years ago you you on a team
where
the goal was to never lose consecutive
games
you guys
in the playoffs made that run where you
didn't lose consecutive games this
year's team i know you guys especially
after all-star break
had a lot of trouble getting healthy but
is there some
character component mental component
that this team lacked in being able to
to win some of these must-win games that
you guys described yourselves
that championship team the guys were
healthy
we had
our closing lineups we had our starting
lineups
we had more this year we had more sign
lineup than we have wins
so
you know we can't
[Music]
you know
i don't know i think that's like i know
it's
repetitive but the health thing is it's
most important like we
you know we try not to lose back-to-back
games that's been kind of like our
mantra didn't entire entire time i've
been here but
um
we're not healthy and guys are who
are not starters or not used to starting
starts or you know guys who who used to
playing
15 minutes play 30 minutes like the
mindset is different
um
you know you
when you have a full team sometimes you
don't play with certain guys you know
you don't have that chemistry
and
now you're playing with them you know
30 minutes 35 minutes and you're trying
to build that chemistry end game and
especially late in the season where you
don't get as much practice time so
you never want to lose back-to-back
games that's kind of been our thing but
health kind of got in the way of that